foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored tone
deaf hypocrite Harry Demands a royal
apology after scaring his family in
books documentaries and interviews but
shouldn't the groveling apology come
from him and his wife before we even
think of them being allowed to attend
the king's coronation
the brother always goes gender-neutral
scrapping male and female categories be
more inclusive and guess what yep no
women then got nominated with chilling
predictability what a fast we'll debate
that later that's President Biden
blasted Donald Trump as totally
irresponsible for keeping classified
documents at home and of course with
equal predictability he's now been
caught doing exactly the same thing I'll
ask kellyanne Conway Trump's former Tom
advisor what she thinks of this
situation
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening for London
welcome to Piers Morgan on censor King
Charles will be crowned in May in a
ceremony gilded by British history
Millions if not billions will watch
around the world as Charles formally
ascends the Throne of westerns to Abbey
where every coronation for the last 957
years has been staged think about that
for a moment a millennium of History our
history Britain history 30 kings and
queens are buried there it's the sacred
place where the late Queen herself was
married and crowned and where she marked
the death of her own husband and that
ribbon of history is what makes the
British Monarchy unique State occasions
that the coronation belong not just to
the Royals but to the people of Britain
and the Commonwealth the very last thing
the coronation needs is a sickening
garnish of the cup price Kardashians
hogging the spotlight and making notes
for the next cash grabbing expose Harry
won't say yet if he'll attend but he's
made his terms very clear
I don't know whether they'll be
you know watching this or not but what
they have to say to me and what I have
to say to them
will be in private and I hope it can
stay that way
the irony is just breathtaking isn't it
416 pages and countless interviews
spewing intimate family secrets now he
wants privacy and according to his
latest whining interview he also wants
the Royals the people he's just been
slaughtering for weeks on end to say
sorry
what I'd really like he says is some
accountability and an apology to my wife
he told the telegraph you know what you
did
well Mrs Beyond parody you know what you
did and I now know why you did it and
you've been caught out so just come
clean he's addressing this to our King
and to our future king and he went on it
was a hundred and pages and now it's
down to 400 Pages it could have been two
books put it that way and the hard bit
was taking things out
he then accused the media of having a
quote bleep ton of dirt about my family
I know they have it and they sweep it
under the carpet for juicy stories about
somebody else
hmm
sound like blackmail to you
in one breath demanding an apology and
the next holding them to Ransom over
what he's held back what maybe to come
what the media may have that they
decided not to publish in return for
terrible stories about Megan and Harry
the delusion of this guy that he thinks
that's how this works that the breasts
get an amazingly Sensational story about
Charles or William and actually after
the palace approached the Press they go
you know what we'll just ditch that one
and we'll run something nasty about
those two in Montecito he's completely
deluded if he thinks that's what happens
this treacherous Little Toad has
forgotten you're supposed to turn into a
prince after being kissed by the spoiled
princess not the other way around last
time a royal abandoned his duties to
hook up the divorced American socialite
it was Edward VII with Molly Simpson now
he never made it to his own coronation
but he did want to attend the ceremony
for his niece Queen Elizabeth Mr Winston
Churchill stepped in and told him to
sling his hook
if Richard sunlight was to do the same
right now would be the most popular
thing he's done so far as prime minister
but before we even so much to think
about whether Harry and Megan should be
allowed anywhere near the coronation and
for me they absolutely should not even
be considered for an invitation one
thing would need to happen
they'd have to go on National Television
they're familiar with the genre plunged
to their knees and issue a global
apology to their families on both sides
who they so mercilessly trashed on every
Airway that is prepared to pay the money
but with these two if you do apologize
to them it's quite interesting isn't it
one person who's made a very groveling
apology today publicly is Jeremy
Clarkson who's now Infamous column on
Megan sparked an avoidable and
predictable backlash to be clear the
comments he said were completely
inappropriate and wrong he shouldn't
have said them it was a dumb joke and I
think he now recognizes judging by his
statement today that it was a moment of
Madness all columnists of Adam I've had
them myself
but he should a long mere culprit on
Instagram
a long one
expressing his deep deep profound regret
but he wasn't enough
Harry spokesman immediately hit back
it's clear this is not an isolated
incident shared in haste but rather a
series of Articles shared in hate
again the irony
a series of Articles shared in hate
does that remind you of anything it
reminds you of a book that's just come
out called spare spewing hate at the
Royal Family
you can stick your apology Harry
where the sun don't shine well joining
me now is former conservative Minister
Ann whitakam and historian Dr Tessa
Dunlop also with his Royal editors for
the Sunday time where Nikka and former
BBC Royal editor Jenny Bond so a
veritable Galaxy of luminaries to debate
this let me start with you Roya again
because you had a big story on Sunday in
which your sources at the palace were
basically indicating that
notwithstanding the onslaught that's
come their way King Charles in
particular was prepared to consider
reconciliation before the coronation in
may now I've got to say before I get you
to talk about that my own sources
tonight who I would describe as pretty
impeccable
um believe that's a bit of a reach say
that Charles is absolutely livid and
actually reconciliation right now is
most definitely not on the cards there's
been no contact whatsoever with anyone
in Montecito and that may well stay the
same so let's let's thrash out our
sources here how confident are you that
you think that Charles really does want
to reconcile with somebody who's really
shown that any attempt to do anything
just immediately gets commercialized
well good evening peers I think sources
aside if you speak to people who really
know the king they will tell you that he
absolutely does not want to be estranged
from his son for the rest of his life
there is no doubt that Charles has lived
the whole royal family prelimited about
what Harry has done but we have a few
months now very very crucial months
leading up to the coronation and
actually one of the most extraordinary
lines in that book was Harry's
Revelation that Charles said to him and
William after Phillip's funeral please
boys don't make the rest of my life a
misery which at the moment
um Harry is doing a very good job of but
watch ours will not want really great
one is estrangement from his son forever
and any kind of major overshadowing of
the coronation and if there is nothing
done no contact at all between now and
the coronation I really do think we're
going to keep peering from Harry and
Megan in a very negative way and and
Charles will want to avoid that but you
know what my response would be it's like
all right keep yapping if you want to
you've done your worst on honestly keep
yapping and just completely ignore them
don't invite them to any Royal events I
mean Jenny Bond why the hell should they
be invited to a coronation it's the
people's coronation it's our coronation
for our Monarch all they've done these
two is damage the monarchy damage the
reputation of that institution damage
their family the royal family on which
the monarchy's future depends but what
on Earth have they done to deserve an
invitation to a coronation well no it's
not just Charles by the way it's Camilla
as well getting crowned who Harry just
trashed in his book
yeah but I think you know this is the
most important day probably in the whole
of Charles's life and if as the loving
father which I believe him to be he
wants his younger son to be there then I
think that is his right and his
privilege and I think an invitation will
be extended to them I I think to not
invite them really is going to be uh
feeding the hand that bites Charles so
it'd be wise to invite them and uh if
they do come uh I think we the media
actually should take it upon ourselves
not to make it not to make it overshadow
the coronation I mean we don't want to
have screaming headlines about them so I
think we should just have a footnote at
the bottom of our coverage of the
coronation and say also in attendance
were the Duke and Duchess of Sussex I
think that might be one approach
you'll be bringing Tesla Dunlop
um look you are the great apologist for
the Megan and Harry here's my question
for you why would two people who hates
everything the Royals seem to stand for
hate the monarchy are intent on
destroying it have done nothing but
trash it and diminish it in the last two
years why on Earth would they want to be
at a coronation of the next monarch of
this country pears I thought you'd read
the full 400 pages of spare then you
will have got the message loud and clear
there is no macro Harry plan he is a
died in the wool royalist no he doesn't
yes I'm afraid he's going about it all
the wrong way he's done unspeakable
damage but he wants to save the money no
no I'm being serious
Tessa let me just respond to that what
he wants is to keep the titles the Royal
titles for him and his wife because it's
the titles that make the money and
they're making hundreds of millions of
dollars his book number one Global
bestseller his documentary series huge
success blah blah blah of course it is
he's trashing the royal family from the
inside it is a boy in pain
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry who grew up in
a goldfish is he in pain or has he ever
been happy which one is it he's telling
us how happy he is he grew up in a
goldfish Bowl who's thrashing his way
out of the Gilded cage but actually as
well as he doesn't know how to exist
without the Gilded oh no he does I
incidentally I'm no apologist for Harry
but I do apologize on your behalf
because one minute you set their peers
and you say oh they'll keep yapping away
they should be ignored there is no way
if they so much has thought that you
would ignore what they say you stoke the
boiler
let me be clear people say this to me
and go why do you keep banging on about
me why do you because they keep trashing
the Royals in podcasts in books in
documentary Series in interviews in ever
stopped and I say to them now I will
stop writing and commenting about them
if they just shut up go to Camp
Montecito be the happy people you keep
telling us that that you are stop
trashing the royal family it's not
attacking harmonically stop diminishing
this country if you do that I'll leave
you alone
the dignified Jenny Bond reduce it to a
footnote
is this doing that because like them you
make money
nobody I bow to nobody of course I do
everybody who's involved in covering the
wrong my case makes fun well you're
making money appearing on this show
tonight double time yeah exactly so
you're making money too out of it so
let's not be Hypocrites do any bond look
no I'm bouncing nobody in my admiration
of Jenny Bond but she would have been
the first in her previous capacities the
BBC's Royal doyan to probably not
actually reduced into a footnote the
coronation because she know it's a big
hot story and this is the problem and
with him isn't it is that is it
unfortunately everywhere they go so does
the lens of attention because they make
it their job to make sure that we don't
leave them alone that is exactly why I
think they should not be at the
coronation for this reason I asked
myself a very straightforward question
which will be the bigger circus if they
don't come or if they do come and if
they come they're likely to be booed we
all know that there'll be a lot of
attention on them because they're well
that'll be the story they get booed at
the coronation exactly whereas if
they're in Montecito I agree we're all
free to concentrate on the coronation so
I feel very strongly they shouldn't come
I also hang on you had a long go I also
feel equally strongly that the Royals
should not be proposing a negotiation
meeting because we've heard Harry's
terms he wants an abject surrender I
wouldn't trust him his father could
throw me that's the point I mean
um this is the problem I would have if I
were Charles and William in particular
um is how do you trust them how do you
trust them given that almost all their
private conversations with Harry have
now appeared in this book including
really intimate stuff including a Prince
Philip's funeral and so on how on Earth
can they trust him to have some sort of
private meeting which stays private
uh well that's a great question and
that's something that's even been
acknowledged by sources close to Harry
and Megan he said to me and I've written
that that
um even they acknowledge that there's an
issue there that perhaps the royal
family might not uh trust that private
stays private but what I would say is as
much as it might stick in the core of
many many members the royal family
particularly the ones you've just
mentioned who come onto heavy fire in
the book I think if the king isn't seen
to somehow do something I think he's
going to come onto even more heavy fire
from his son and other people down the
line but but that will be the great test
I think if they if they do propose some
sort of I'm not saying a negotiation but
some sort of sit down and then something
leaks out and it comes from Harry and
Megan's side then I think it probably is
game over but at least the king may have
tried yeah I mean Jenny Bond it is a I
feel incredibly sorry for for Charles
he's lost both his parents in the space
of two years he's probably still
mourning his mother just died a few
months ago he's taken on the monarchy
you know he's our new monarch he's about
to be crowned the king of this great
country tree I mean all these huge
pressures both personally and
professionally and then he's got his his
young son causing just total endless
Relentless Mayhem I mean my if that was
one of my sons I've said to them I've
got three boys in my 20s one of you does
this to me and goes Rogue like this
that's it Bang there won't be any
reconciliation parties you're done
well you see I don't think he wants to
lose his son as well as having lost his
parents and I do think that Charles is
quite a compassionate guy and I think he
would probably agree with me that what
we're witnessing here is almost the
unraveling of a youngish man who um is
so mentally fragile now and so confused
there's so many errors in the book
um and conflicted within himself and
really suffering and I yeah
I said some terrible things
I want to pick you up on that thing
about the mental health thing I don't
see somebody suffering or in pain I see
a smug little narcissist making a ton of
cash abusing and revealing secrets about
his family I don't see anyone fragile
whatsoever
on the one hand he says I'm the happiest
I've ever been on the other hand he
wants us to believe he's a pain struck
young guy he's not he's nearly 40. you
know he's had a long time to get over of
the painter by the way millions of
people have to go through losing parents
when they're young it's not not
exclusive to him his own brother went
through exactly the same thing and
doesn't seem to feel the need to trash
his family in public so I just don't
really Buy in Jenny to this you know
he's racked with pain and is so fragile
I think he doesn't give a damn about the
damage to the mental health of all his
relatives and yet he's supposed to be
the prince of Mental Health
I think he is racked with pain and in
his book I thought it was very very
moving when he said that when he for a
second lot of therapy
um he was frightened of losing the pain
he had felt for all those years for the
loss of his mother he was frightened of
losing that pain in the therapy because
he would lose his mother again and I
thought it was incredibly moving now I'm
not going to defend Harry for all he's
done or he's said a lot of it's
abominable most of it's loopy and I
agree I think he's he's a little bit
unbalanced and deluded perhaps because
all the drugs he took I don't know
his mental health I think he's a I think
he's a California all the time when
you're out there uh Tessa Dunlop you've
been raging away you know what have I
said this wrong you are renowned for
lacking empathy I won't use I've got
plenty of members
I actually have a lot of empathy for the
right people actually and my entire
career
empathy no no I so empathy for the
people who deserve it Harry is not
deserving
who has watched Harry from birth through
the death of his mother you don't have a
shred of empathy for his peculiar
lifestyle that's trained him for nothing
that's left him with job loads of
expectations
and I went to a state school and
actually what he should have done is go
to a state school and you'll grimacing
yeah I'm absolutely just just calm down
the pair of you uh perfectly calm
neither of you signed it at the moment
now can I just Rich coming from you
you're normally the one blowing up but
go on I've actually sat here trying to
get a word for a long time
I mean let me make this point the
coronation is not just a personal
occasion now you can understand the
father wants to involve his son in all
sorts of things and it's but it's not a
royal wedding it's a coronation it's an
occasion of State
and you've got to ask yourselves what is
the most dignified way that we can have
this because it is an occasion of state
and therefore there must be a great deal
of dignity that won't be by having Harry
Potter I totally agree it would be
literally like having the Kardashians
sitting there uh please stay with me uh
my panel here Roy are we going to say
goodbye to Roy another busy week for you
I know you're writing busily away again
presumably your next big scoop on Sunday
so thank you we're looking forward to
speaking to you about that whenever it
drops I appreciate you joining us thank
you very much we'll stay with the panel
because after the break we're going to
talk to a guardian journalist who wrote
A fascinating piece this week for last
week in which in detail why it wasn't
the tabloids who actually Harry should
be blaming for what happened to his
mother and as one of the Tablo editors
at the time she died I agree so we'll
talk to him after the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ludicrous decision to go gender-neutral
which meant that cause no women got any
nominations who could have predicted
that oh that would be me and we're going
to talk about Joe Biden who is basically
forgetting people's names again and also
be knighting documents at his home
deliberately is he any better or worse
than Trump when he comes to that kind of
thing we'll see there's him singing
happy birthday to somebody or he forgot
the name cringe making you'll watch it
later on uh anyway let's get back to the
the Royal debate because I um I
mentioned earlier about Jeremy Clarkson
oh listen I get on phone with glass and
now but just to remind viewers he did
punch me in the head and I've got a sky
which comes up when I have a town I can
do now from his right fist so it's not
like we've been the easiest of bed there
we are easiest of bed fellows over the
years I've literally bombed the scars of
Clarkson so I'm not going to be his
greatest cheerleader in a moment of
Misfortune all I would say is this is
that he could not have issued a more
sincere apology than he did today and as
I've always suspected about the white
Brigade the moment you do that they
don't accept it and by the way Harry's
the king of the wokies they just Chuck
it straight back in your face
and I I'm interested we didn't discuss
this but here's my problem with it if it
can't he apologize enough I mean is
there no apology oh it's acceptable if
you're not rummage around in the small
print it's because the grand Tours
apparently been pulled by Amazon Prime
that apology well we don't know that's
all because
smell the coffee I'd rather wait why do
you think Clarkson apologize why dip you
down in your typical do you think he
should be canceled for everything
to be honest I think we've had quite a
lot of Clarkson over the years and time
to bring on a fresh lot yeah I would
have you think he should be canceled for
that reason canceled he's still
platformed everything yeah
I think maybe if the Amazon Prime think
it's time for them to shuffle off then
perhaps
I haven't confirmed that I mean he won't
answer the question do you think he
should well that's a good question I
think this should be a punishment for
that level of virtual I would like to
see and don't shoot me I would like to
see some modification to the to the to
include misogyny in those haters
institutional I agree with it so what
about all the hideously misogynistic
things that Harry says in his book oh
not back to that not back to the prep
school teacher whom he made laugh yeah
when he was 11 years old
you've got to let me finish I'm talking
about the matron that he called ugly and
greasy and didn't make the boys horny
I'm talking about the newspaper
executive who is absolutely viciously
misogynist about I'm talking about
Camilla who he calls a dangerous villain
blah blah blah blah blah blah the book
is laced with misogyny so I agree he
shouldn't be taken more seriously what
about he starts with himself
first of all would you have preferred
that he pretended he was a saint at prep
school and never did that
children did
requests
my question she was very simple why
should he be allowed to be a misogynist
but anyone who dares to be a misogynist
about his wife he wants to get cancer I
just don't think you can compare the
idea of someone of course he can being
sentient liked on a cellular level of
course having human accent we're
describing a tabloid actually something
what he said about a female editor was
actually pretty well
actually it was misogynist sexist and
revolting yeah uh but anyway let's move
on I want to talk to Stephen Bates
former Guardian World corresponder age
Stephen I didn't even know the guardian
had a royal correspondence so that was a
bit of a shock to me so congratulations
on on that on that title uh but thank
you for joining me look I wanted to get
you one because I expect you to launch a
spirited full frontal defense of tabloid
newspaper but I do think you're very
very interesting points in your column
about all this which is that Harry's
real point of visceral hatred is that
the British tabloids in particular were
directly to blame for princess Diner his
mother's death and you wrote at a column
really saying that isn't born by facts
no that's right I mean I watched the ITV
interview uh the other Sunday like
millions of other people did and as you
see we had this riff about
um the tabloids uh and the paparazzi
causing his mother's death that wasn't
actually what I discovered and found I
was the Guardians man in Brussels at the
time and I was sent down first thing
that morning to help the coverage of
course and I got on into a cab at the
guardian North to go to the guardian
office and the cabbie this is five or
six hours after the accident said that
driver must have been mad to drive into
that tunnel at that speed he said
there's a very bad camber and there's a
Twist in the tunnel and anyone who
drives in at that sort of speed you have
to stick to 30 kilometers an hour he
said you know anyone who went in at the
sort of speed that car was being driven
at uh must have been mad and we now know
after the inquest which I also covered
eight years later at the high court
that Omri poll the chauffeur that
evening was high on drink and drugs he
hadn't been expecting to work which is
why why he was drunk and he'd never
driven a Mercedes before and Muhammad
al-fahed instructed him to drive Dodie
and Diana right across Paris a route he
didn't particularly know in a very fast
car that he wasn't used to driving he
had a mini himself
and he showed off he was showing off to
the paparazzi who were outside the Ritz
hotel they could have stayed at the Ritz
hotel because they had a suite there
they were rooted out of The Suite by
Mohamed al-fied who wanted them to stay
at his apartment and that was the
terrible thing that happened and the
other crucial thing I think this is and
the other point I was going to make
which I think is really important to
this is that Harry talks sort of vaguely
about there were flashing lights as his
mother and the car she was in crashed in
fact the paparazzi were not within one
kilometer of the car when it crashed
that came out of the request so there
were there were none of them anywhere
near that's right that's right or the
car what is completely true is that once
they caught up with the car on it and
they realized that they crashed then
some of these ghouls did actually try
and take pictures of Diana lying in the
back of the car and that is that is
completely unforgivable but it's not
true that they were right with the car
as it went into the tunnel blinding
giant the driver potentially with with
their flash bulbs
that's absolutely right they were on
Vespers fence Vespers don't outrun
Mercedes being driven at speed they were
behind they were admittedly chasing the
Mercedes and probably trying to catch up
with it at lights or something like that
but they weren't in front of it and so
therefore they didn't cause the accident
they indeed did behave like ghouls
afterwards these were Continental
Paparazzi it has to be said they weren't
British journalists they weren't British
photographers they were Italians and
French maybe they wanted to sell
photographs to the British tabloids but
I doubt very much whether the British
tabloids which by then had learned their
lesson well I can tell you well I can
tell you for a fact that I was in The
Daily Mirror Newsroom in the early hours
of that morning about 5 a.m when we were
offered pictures of Dinah lying in the
back of the car didn't know if she was
dead or alive at that stage it turned
out she actually died I think on the way
to hospital when she got to hospital but
these pictures were offered to us and I
not only refused to even countenance
using them I rang the head of the agency
who'd sent them in advised him very
strongly to withdraw them from
everywhere he'd sent them and to leave
the country and keep his head down
because it might cost him his entire
business so this idea that we were
sitting there and salivating over
pictures of Diana in the back of the car
is completely untrue
there are many things you can claim the
tabloids for about their Royal coverage
of Diana and Charles and the breakup of
all uh that marriage but that is not one
of them uh it seems to have embittered
Harry uh very deeply you can understand
that but um as I think you were saying
earlier
um it's probably time unfortunately that
he should get over it well you know I I
would never tell anyone to get over the
death of a parent and that's thing but I
certainly think that him continuing to
apportion direct blame on a particular
section of the British media for the
crash that killed his mother is just
unfortunately it's not borne out by the
facts Jenny Bond you were covering
Stephen thank you very much indeed for
joining me Jenny you listening to all
that are you obviously covering all this
I mean it is to me it's a very important
point you can have a view as as Harry
and William both do that the paparazzi
are the enemy for them because they
follow them all around at all times and
obviously Diner got more attention that
I think anybody else did and the rules
did all change after she died actually
but that doesn't mean that the press the
British press were to blame for her
death that's just not true
no it's not true and I've never bought
into the conspiracy theory whatsoever
but um Harry seems to want to revive
that he was traumatized by what happened
however it happened and he has not been
able to get over it and for that that's
why I say we have to have some some
sympathy with him but uh you know he's
in the book he suggested that he would
like and William would like uh to have
the inquest reopened or the inquiry
reopened though he doesn't know what you
gained from it
um obviously that's not going to happen
but I I don't know how he will ever
um be reconciled with what happened to
his mother never be never mind be
reconciled no well you have to look
Jenny thank you very much for joining me
I mean look the bottom line and you've
got to stick to facts the inquest was
unbelievably thorough and she wasn't
wearing a seat belt and she wasn't
wearing a seat belt the car was speeding
the driver was drunk and had drugs in
his body uh and he was basically lost
control of the car on a bump in the
under bus I mean that's what happened it
is
the one person who survived that crash
was the only person who was wearing a
seat belt I interviewed him I had the
first interview with Trevor Reese Jones
a bodyguard and does he uphold Harry's
version well he all here I mean look he
wore the seatbelt and that saved his
life the others weren't wearing seat
belts
does he say that they were trying to
escape the paparazzi no no because
the paparazzi were over a kilometer
behind them there were no near the car
so it wasn't the paparazzi and by the
way as Stephen Riley pointed out these
weren't British press these were foreign
Paparazzi just talking about this
reliving it even in a sort of fourth
hand version It's horrific it's painful
I think what we need to do is I know
this is going to be difficult for you
peers and perhaps you too Ann but it's
cut Harrison slack lift ourselves above
the parapet and think what is the royal
family for it is our first family it's a
great British brand do we want it to
look magnanimous do we want it to
represent redemption and forgiveness if
we do what about him
he's doing none of that
I can tell you the best way to do that
is not to invite those yeah anywhere
near the coronation but thank you Tessa
thank you Ann appreciate you coming in
I've got to come the bread Awards goes
gender neutral to be more inclusive and
with obvious predictability all five
nominees for best artists identify as
men do gender-neutral Awards exclude
women who are going to have a
gender-neutral panel if this these two
carry on
it's gone give each other a hug
do that we'll be back up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Brit awards are a month
away but we already know one thing about
this is best artist it will be a man or
somebody currently identifying as a man
the UK's biggest Music Awards introduced
supposedly inclusive gender neutral
Awards last year I predicted very
quickly on Twitter this would be a
complete disaster would mean women would
get excluded and guess what all five
nominees for the top best artist prize
are male this is what Adele had to say
about the decision last year when
picking up her award for artists of the
year
I understand why the name of this award
has changed but I really love being a
woman and being a female artist I do
I do yeah sorry adult but you're not
allowed to be a woman anymore not to be
a female artist uh has to be gender
neutral here's my gender neutral panel
joined by Sam Fox who presented the
Brits of course
um yeah so Sam look to me this was in
completely predictable situation and
what's made me laugh is all those
screaming loudest for gender-neutral
awards yeah are actually the ones now
screaming foul because they've taken the
five best artists of the year they
happen to be men yeah but listen cheers
who has chosen these men probably men
would you reckon well I don't think they
chose them because they're a man I think
they chose them because they were best
but they happen to be men that's why you
have a female category to make sure you
have the best male artist and best
female artist yeah because then you
screw them he just came back the wrong
way for you Lord didn't it that's the
problem do you know what I think what
would be best to do in this situation
there's only five people in that
category best artist yeah yeah if
they're now putting the best female
artist and the best male into one
category then they should they should be
10 nominees not five
they're twice as long an award show do
me a favor there should be more choice
no well there should be it's best woman
artist best male artist what's wrong
with it over it doesn't fit into those
cartoons anymore we're not there but
we're talking about he's born male or
female no no come on no that's not some
people may want to change I know you're
all born trust me you're all born
sexually male no female
seriously as I know somebody who was
born with a penis but my soul had yes he
was a man born with a penis but then
when he got to a certain age he
developed breasts and when they looked
into it he had ovaries what does he eat
after I didn't ask but these are these
are such rare occasions we're talking
about people who know like Sam Smith who
I don't know what award he's up for one
year you to the next one minute is this
next minute is that then he's this then
he's that how do you keep up with him
you have a gender-neutral category which
solves that doesn't it have male female
and the rest of you right
I don't care what you want to call
yourselves I don't care what you think
you are in any given moment Sam Smith
who changed literally more than a
chameleon it can be whatever he wants
and you park them into the corner and
you say Right male female and the rest
everything else and the rest can all
compete with each other but here's my
question for you over let's take gender
neutrality to his logical conclusion
let's have a gender neutral Olympics and
you know what would happen women would
never win a medal again I don't think
other than a bit equestrian action and a
bit of shooting that's not the same
music music is not the same you know
music is is a brilliant thing about
music is that it gives people
um uh license to express themselves as
women
as people as people yeah
no actually Adele sings about about life
and love and breakups from the
perspective of a woman that's why she
wants to win female artists of the year
I've been singing about a woman once
okay so what if a woman what are you
suggesting I don't know Adele might tell
me
boundaries what do you know that we
don't know well where do we know you
know I've written songs about lovers in
my life you don't know if it's a male or
female I think in your case both uh do
you know I think you just wrote about it
in your book didn't you yeah
British Airways you get on British
Airways right and somebody says good
afternoon welcome ladies and gentlemen
to your British Airway and I feel
immediately soothed right now it's good
afternoon persons of it's everything
indiscriminated
if you're non-binary you're welcome on
this flight oh shut up just go back to
ladies and gentlemen it's the last night
I was in Germany yeah doing a a concert
there's many many people there and I'm
not going to say good evening ladies and
gentlemen no I'm going to say good
evening everybody why don't you say
ladies and gentlemen because there's not
only ladies and gentlemen
what I mean what is wrong with ladies
and gentlemen and everything else what
about the right of a somebody who wants
to be called a lady or in my case wants
to be called a gentleman where is my
right to continue being called a
gentleman why am I right eroded
why are they why do you need that why
are they eroding why can't I be called
if you know you're a gentleman why do
you need to be reminded by someone if
you know you're non-binary why have you
got to be called that you don't need to
do anything you're just being we're just
saying good afternoon to everyone
everything gender neutral I like
feminine things I like masculine things
I like women I like males I like females
I'm fed up with this clap true and most
people are you know what this is 100
people in the street do you think this
is claptruck they'll go it is complete
laughter peers keep saying it's clap
track 100 people in the street they
wouldn't even know that British Airways
were doing that they'd have no idea what
if they've flown British Airways
British Airways staff don't want to do
it either they've been told to do it
peers can I just ask you something did
you use the loo before you came on
television I use my dressing room Lou
which has male only can I just say now
well I've just went to the lou and it's
got a man and a woman on the door right
[Music]
either
don't know one of the time you don't
share them anyway look we don't share
one cubicle here is the well what is
that what is that it's a man of the
woman well that's where you've been
proven that's actually not a toilet
that's a little love parlor no no
Britain's uh universities descending
into woke Madness I'm going to talk
about Joe Biden the leader of the Free
World is inability to remember anything
ever I'll be off the break
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when somebody's birthday sing happy
birthday you ready happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
Devin
happy birthday to you
her name is Andrea Mr President she's
the daughter-in-law of Martin Luther
King it's Martin Luther King Day in
America so now you know her name is
Andrea let's hear it again
have we got it again
no
okay we did have it again have we got it
again
well look my wife has a rule on her
family
when somebody's birthday sing happy
birthday you ready happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear Evan
happy birthday to you
unbelievable well I'm still here with my
stellar pack Samsung I didn't introduce
uh Ava Santina Esther cracker because I
didn't know what they were currently
identifying at so until I had that
confirmation on the break I couldn't
call the master and and Ava but joining
me now is the former senior Council to
president Trump kellyanne Conway well
kellyanne lovely to have you back on the
program first of all your reaction to
that I mean it's barely a week goes by
without President Biden forgetting
something but on Martin Luther King Day
to forget the name of someone who's
related to Martin Luther King as you
sing Happy Birthday to her and it's your
idea to sing it that is a cringe moment
isn't it
it is but it's a lease that President
Biden's problem not that he forgot the
woman's name and embarrassed himself
it's that he forgot he had classified
documents National Security Secrets
stuffed near his Corvette in his
Delaware house going to come to yeah
because it's a more serious right
because yeah look let's come to the more
serious uh story are you serious hey hey
pierce the other the other the other
thing with Biden is these aren't gaffes
I mean the guy is not doing well I'm a
big critic of Republicans who run around
all day incessantly making fun of Joe
Biden's obvious mental and physical lack
of Acuity and challenges because I think
it creates some sympathy for him and it
distracts from the disaster that is his
presidency and in this case not just the
double standard but the Prima fascia
case that he has violated the law I
don't need to hear Donald Trump's name I
don't need to hear we're sorry I don't
need to hear we didn't mean it
inadvertently mishandled the law doesn't
care about your feelings it doesn't care
I want to explain to viewers what you're
talking about because I'm a team that up
but Donald Trump as we know was caught
with a bunch of classified documents and
is facing potential serious legal
Jeopardy as a result but what I remember
as that story unfold was the Democrats
making a lot of hay while the Sun's on
and saying this is one of the most
terrible things they'd ever seen and
these same Democrats now that Joe Biden
has been found to have had classified
documents at his home including in his
car in his office and so on the same
Democrats he was so outraged by what
happened with Donald Trump I've now gone
a bit quiet now it's their guy it's the
hypocrisy I can't stomach
that's right and the country will be
with you by and large except for those
adult with Trump derangement syndrome
for which there is no vaccine and no
booster most people will look at this
and increasingly appears members of the
mainstream media are looking at this and
they're not taking be quiet for an
answer from the White House Press
briefing room they're not taking it from
the special counsel in Biden because
they know that their job is to seek out
transparency to make sure hold the
government accountable make sure it's
transparent and on this one it wasn't
just the quote Biden people and the
Democrats saying oh look at president
Trump look what he's done he needs to go
to jail it was Joe Biden himself an
interview on 60 Minutes saying and I
quote how could this possible
so irresponsible I've got the clip let's
play it go for it when you saw the
photograph of the top secret documents
laid out on the floor at Mar-A-Lago what
did you think to yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or Etc
and it just uh totally irresponsible
you can say that again Mr President
because it's just happened to you and
you actually had done exactly the same
thing at the precise moment that you
were hectoring and lecturing everybody
else including Donald Trump about being
irresponsible and what are sift gears uh
come back in a moment this thing a pack
about woke universities
big story in America big story in
Britain now the big study of the elite
universities in Britain Oxford and
Cambridge at the top of the list of woke
ravaged
atmosphere at these places where
including Aberdeen University for
example put a trigger warning on Peter
Pan because it might be emotionally
challenging to students over this stuff
is the stuff of Madness the whole point
of the university is you get challenged
emotionally isn't it I mean I think
there is a challenge I think they're
just presenting you with a trigger
warning I don't why why isn't he warning
I don't really understand why you
concern yourself with what people at
University are doing they're students
they're the future of this country yeah
okay and if they're triggered by it then
maybe that is they shouldn't be anywhere
near a university the whole point is you
get your own views challenge that that
is them getting their race of a trigger
warning what does it do though does that
mean that they don't have to read it no
it doesn't at all it just means it's a
warning of what the content inside is
Japan is going to upset you funnily
enough Bristol University's third which
is why am I on the University I went to
so that's not surprising I think I'm I'm
curious about what they mean by work
though because I think sometimes it can
be a bit lazy if you're saying that the
idea is the students aren't being
challenged or there's material being
removed from the curriculum because
that is fair the difference is this work
actually originally meant just being
more aware of Social and racial
Injustice we can all sign up to that but
kellyanne we've got the same thing in
America with this is that universities
are becoming so pathetically weak that
students need endless trigger warnings
about stuff like Peter Pan it's
completely mad
it's completely mad and it's it's why
people are really questioning where to
send their kids to school in this
country you hear a lot of these seniors
I have two of them in high school a lot
of their friends saying maybe I'll go
south maybe you know Wide Open Spaces
friendly faces where you don't have to
get somebody to sign an affidavit to
invite them to have an ice cream cone
and by the way we already hurt these
kids who are now going to college the
kova generation we lock them down we let
them down for too long very difficult
for them in isolation very difficult for
them to get a rhythm and a routine which
is what you get in high school and then
what you're supposed to get in college
at University peers we're denying them
also which is a free-for-all in terms of
communication to suss out the the facts
and opinions and and the whole point by
the way I don't think we know each other
anymore
they really are University is supposed
to be where you formulate better
opinions because you have smart people
around you saying the complete opposite
and you debate it and you reach points
of agreement and you evolve and you
learn not where you go and cry because
you have to read beat a ban and someone
forgot to do a little Trigger walk it is
pathetic lovely to see you Sam lovely to
see you back thank you all very much
indeed remember keep it unsensitive for
the love of God don't cry about Peter
Bang Tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign